If you've been watching the White House corona
virus press briefings, you've probably realized
by now that it is all coming off the walls.
And the World Mental Health Coalition is now
urging Donald Trump to resign over being,
as they say, severely mentally troubled in
the middle of a pandemic.
The Corona virus pandemic, which is leading
to increasingly horrifying numbers of deaths
here in the United States.
The White House meant I'm sorry, the.
The World Mental Health Coalition posted a
prescription for survival where they point
out that they've been warning about Trump
since 2017.
They've had countless psychiatrists point
out the dangers of Donald Trump in a position
of power on countless issues.
And now with the Corona virus pandemic spreading
and Trump completely on the wrong side of
just about every element of it.
While increasingly belligerent in his delusions
of grandeur, the weight of the World Mental
Health Coalition now outlines a prescription
for what they believe should happen.
And this includes some combination of using
the 25th Amendment to remove Trump, a new
impeachment attempt on the basis of his mishandling
of Corona virus.
Trump straight up resigning.
A court ordered mental health eval or the
removal of his decision making ability on
Corona virus, as well as the suspension of
the White House press briefings themselves,
suggesting that it should really be the CDC
doing these briefings without political interference,
which I agree with now.
Unfortunately, none of these things are going
to happen.
Donald Trump's cabinet is not going to invoke
the 25th Amendment on Trump.
They're just not.
It's a tough to even dream of.
A different outcome is simply not based in
reality.
Impeaching Trump over this, even if the House
impeach Trump over his corona virus response.
It's not going to happen in the Senate.
So that isn't going to be happening.
Trump is obviously not going to resign the
presidency.
There will, of course, be no mental health
evaluation forced on Donald Trump.
And nobody is going to remove Trump's decision
making power on the virus.
As far as Trump stuff.
Stopping the press briefings.
Good luck, Trump.
Yesterday, for example, wasn't even scheduled
to do a press briefing, but told people around
him, hey, it's free TV and they get good ratings.
So that is not something that is going to
change.
Trump can't do rallies right now because of
social distancing.
So he's doing the press briefings instead.
So we have a situation where the United States
is thirty ninth in the world in per capita
testing, not first, as Donald Trump has now
claimed multiple times.
The U.S. response was slow.
It was ran a wrong headed on many fronts,
which we've outlined to you.
Daily Trump is spreading disinformation like
it'll go away like a miracle in April.
We have 15 cases and we will soon have zero.
Sometimes a scarf is more effective than a
mask and on and on and on.
But in the midst of all of this, the only
opportunity to remove Donald Trump is in November
by voting him out.
And that is something he is going to make
as difficult as possible for people to do.
Now, of course, I'm not arguing that the World
Mental Health Coalition is wrong.
Of course they are right.
Trump's presidency has become deadly.
On this issue, as if it wasn't already deadly
before on a number of different issues.
But expecting any of these suggestions?
You know, Reza, 25th Amendment resignation
forcing a mental health evaluation on Trump.
It's just not gonna happen.
So let's focus our energy on two things that
we know work.
What do we know works?
Social distancing works.
Now, unfortunately, more and more right wing
churchgoers are not only ignoring social distancing,
they are scofflaws.
When it comes to it.
They are deliberately doing the exact opposite.
We'll get to that later in the show.
But social distancing works and we should
be doing it.
Number two, voting Trump out in November.
You don't need to convince Trump's cabinet
to invoke any amendment.
You don't need to force anything on you.
Just vote him out.
OK, so he is not going to be removed by any
of these other means that I've mentioned.
Let's do what we can.
Social distance now.
Remove Trump in November.